hey guys welcome to the evident Kaitlyn
podcast brought to you by cat hair cat
hair it's everywhere that intro was
written by Andrew Bill's thank you for
the intro if you guys want your intro to
be in our podcast you can tweet us on
Twitter with the hashtag UK podcast
intro intro because we just released our
art cactus project and we did it an ad
in the beginning at where we like it was
an ad for Dyson and we wanted to like
show vacuuming up cat hair and so I've
been like I felt so creepy doing that
watching MacGyver hat hair for several
days before so we have like a little
brush I was brushing her extra and I was
like yes give this to me there's like
places she always sits out on the couch
I'm a good way to like especially for
like couches and stuff if you get rubber
shower squeegees doing really help get
up pat hair pet hair I was like pet and
cat yes the other pants
and so I was like doing that nose like
haha look at my juicy like put it in the
baggie needed like a couple days to
collect you know and I can't believe
that we got her to sit down on her own
cat hair I thought was just so lucky for
that she was just gonna eat it I'm just
also so happy oh by the way the podcast
is gonna be about home renovation and
all of our thoughts around that but side
story I'm just so happy that that that
video is doing well right know we just
released it like a couple hours ago
three and a half hours ago the cactus
video yeah Anna launched at a number one
spot amongst our past 10 which is just
like so exciting cause they're like like
it's not that we ever really doubted
that we like had lost what we were doing
but like I think one has been a while
since you've had like a number one
you're like am I losing it am I losing
it have I lost my edge
do we not even know what we're doing
anymore do you not know what our
audience wants from us it's like great
job your videos performing as usual it
gives you like it ranked your past 10
videos in terms of how they perform in
the first hour two hours three hours
like compares them and it tells you a
little evaluation yeah and it it keeps
saying like great job but it'll be like
number four and we're like what number
eight and we're like as usual it's like
in the normal deviation of spread of our
video so it's like yeah yeah you did
another video good job
fine but it's like that's fine is like
at number one of our past showing that
like our channels still healthy and that
we have ideas that are good cute giant
things cute giant thing so it's like
what what do you think the thing was I
think there's a ton of aspects that may
go into like well I think it's like
there's like a nerves like what made
this video do well I think it's like one
aspect of it is like this - that another
aspect is you say when you say this -
that you mean the transformation that we
showed in the thumbnail I go from my
balloon to this funky looking cat shapes
yeah
also it's like a novel thing that like
I'm not sure if it's been done before
you know I haven't seen it done I've
seen like individual elements of this
done
yeah but not combined in the way that we
so it's like a new thing it's a this -
that it's like people want to see how it
like asks a question even though we're
not asking a question it's like how did
they get from that to that I know we can
analyze things from with 20/20 hindsight
and try to guess that what it was but
really we still don't know I'm really
proud of our video in other news it
finally got cold I know it's so great -
where we talked about the weather but
it's been so hot here for so long yeah
so it's so good to have it be 60
although so okay the catio we made it
like in the late spring it was already
pretty toasty here in Texas it was
already like hit in the 90s and and cats
like it warm
like they prefer a temperature of like
80 to 85 degrees
yeah and so she's been loving it all
summer and she went out she hops out
there and it's like 96 degrees it is
like chill and so this morning you know
the cold front had come in and she she
hops out there and she's like what and a
breeze blows and she gets all tense and
she's like what the what just looking up
immediately she's done that twice this
morning already think so she wants out
majula nope still too cold yeah so we
might have to like put some blankets in
there like some towels the thing is like
it rains on and off sometimes too and I
don't want things see gross William like
if we know it's not gonna rain or
something out there and we'll take it in
at night another update is when this
comes out we'll have already been there
but we're gonna be heading to a local
makerspace here in Houston the maker
barn and we're gonna be giving away some
of the machines we've been accumulating
which is kind of it's a good thing it's
a necessary thing just because we don't
use them anymore and I'd rather have
them being used and appreciated by
people than just sitting here taking up
space in our house because it's like not
benefiting us it's like almost hurting
us because it's just taking up space and
you know and by machines we're talking
specifically like 3d printers 3d
printers and a few other tools and still
yeah and I think that you know they're
they're stuff that we got when it made
sense for us we made our money using it
you know it's uh we used to sell I think
we've talked about it before we used to
sell products to asked alum we used to
sell things and that was the idea that
we had like I just kind of envisioned
like a room full of like 20 to 30 3d
printers printing all day with like
cloud-enabled connections and I can just
like wake up in the morning be running
all the time and making money for us
just like printing games that we can
sell and you know we can monetize and we
did do that I mean not a roomful but we
had a waffle yeah of 3d printers doing
that making products that's just not our
identity anymore and I think the thing
is even
you know we've talked about this in
podcast we'd like a whole video about
small-scale manufacturing and utilizing
something like 3d printers does
definitely help if you're trying to like
oh yeah make more products without
hiring outsourcing work but there's
still a decent amount of human
involvement because we sold to paint
them finish them mount them make the
wood backings all the background stuff
yeah yeah all the backend stuff and
there's just not time to do that and
make videos but it is kind of weird like
getting rid of the extra 3d printers and
we're still keeping a couple yeah
because they still use them for videos
but getting rid of the extras is like
we're officially closing closing my
chapter yeah yeah so you know I think
it's good it's good to kind of like
decide choose decide and move forward as
opposed to just like leaving it in an
undecided limbo state yeah I mean even
though we had already kind of I mean we
had kind of closed the chapter on making
stuff but I feel like for me it was
still a little bit of like well maybe
there's something else we'll use this
for maybe there's a different type of
product we might start making that
doesn't require all the human
interaction maybe or maybe like we'll do
some project that requires a ton of 3d
printing and we'll need them all running
back but then like you know if it's like
honestly now I'm I'm saying something I
haven't fully thought through so take it
with a grain of salt if we're gonna be
doing a ton of 3d printing one thing we
might do is you know we might reach out
to like we know someone who has a 3d
printer farm in Houston you know or we
could order from like an online store
that that prints them at a reasonable
price and and for us our time is more
valuable than then you know the the
slight cost savings of like so it's like
okay prototype that like first few or
the idea or whatever here with our
printers that we have here and then if
we need to print a ton of one thing or
like bigger things or just a huge volume
of them what does order it that's yeah
you know I like that's like well what we
need is we need the stuff that will get
us like through the day-to-day and
really one or two 3d printers is kind of
ah meaning kind of all we needed yeah
that's what we're like we're paring it
down to just I think we're keeping -
yeah yeah and if you guys don't know
we'll kind of link some resources down
below I mean we even have like we've set
up a store on one 3d printing website
where if people don't have 3d printers
they can buy our items and have them
shipped straight to them like the ring
that Caitlin and I designed together or
the necklace or something like that yeah
yeah
but anyways one of the reasons that we
are going through this stuff and getting
rid of it is the 3d printers live on the
3d printing cart the 3d printing cart
lives in the guest room and we are in
the middle of a guest room makeover for
a video yes so so that's why we've kind
of been forced to look at things and
figure out what we what we need and it's
not just the printers just a lot of like
accessories and stuff to that we're
giving away and all that'll open up a
lot of space but that kind of leads us
to our topic because it's kind of a home
renovation real makeover various
transition thanks our topic is a
question that was submitted to us a
series of questions actually by
blackharts creations and I guess the
overall theme is I'd love to hear more
about your time renovating your house
and there's a bunch of questions so I
thought it'd be cool to go through them
one by one and just talk about like
house renovating house buying house DIY
tips old were we when we bought our
house 6 yeah 25 or 26 25 or 26 before we
were married yeah yeah so we bought we
bought our house I feel like relatively
younger than most other people we knew
and we bought it
Oh mainly for financial reasons well I
think it was a mix I think part of it
was financial reasons because it's
really like low interest rate it seemed
like a good investment boy like like
looking at the monthly cost of the house
verse the apartment that we wanted to
live in because we you know we wanted
like you know a
apartment for the two of us and we
wanted to be in a certain area and you
know all these requirements and stuff
and our apartment price kept on going up
and that really annoyed both of us I
think that that was like a big factor
really this is unfair well hi does the
monthly rent keep on going up and I know
that's just part of the business plan of
apartments but it's like it's going up
at an unreasonable rate I know I was
going on I think there's a lot of things
the apartment we lived at was close to
your job yeah but then you switch jobs
oh yeah and so we were looking at new
apartments because you're the apartment
wasn't near and I was working from home
at the time so my job wasn't an issue
but we were like okay well since we're
looking at new apartments why don't we
look at houses too because you know this
apartment that we were so like indignant
about the price increase is actually
cheaper than any other apartment we can
move to yeah and so why don't we just
look at houses and plus at the time I
was really into home DIY read a lot of
young house love and chris loves julia
and it just seemed so fun to have your
own space that you could do more stuff
to than you can do in the department
mm-hmm yeah so like I'm not gonna lie
those kind of these a little bit of the
appeal
that's so just raisins are part of it I
think for me I was just like upset that
our apartment could just increase our
ranch to whatever it wanted to know like
this is stupid
it's like Elias like show me some
economical breakdowns of why it's
increasing at the rate like like you
know whoa justify this I know if they
had I might have been more okay with the
pricing pieces but I still probably
would've wanted to move out yeah
especially because like we were looking
to potentially move anyway and the house
that we ended up buying this house that
we're at right now we we jump on it
right away
because we recognized that this was the
right house but the whole house buying
process we actually have a whole blog
post on app that will link down below
house buying for newbs it was like the
first thing we did on the blog that like
got some traction on Pinterest oh my god
yeah yeah we did a whole blog post on it
because we felt super passionate about
the information that we needed wasn't
out there in the format that we wanted
and we could understand yeah everything
was like if you're a first-time
homebuyer
everything out there is so confusing you
know it wasn't it just wasn't broken
down so while it was still fresh we were
like okay we're gonna basically write a
guide for our future selves yeah you
know or like what we would have wanted
to to look at but it was also
interesting because we oh my gosh we
looked at so many houses yeah we looked
at a bunch together but then I also
looked at a bunch without you because I
was like Oh many houses like probably 50
houses yeah because I am really
particular we almost bought one house we
almost like jumped for a house that was
like more expensive than we needed and
bigger way bigger than we needed
although looking back maybe we could
have made use of this but yeah we almost
well we had we had already been looking
for so long and then we found this house
that was exactly in the air area we
wanted exactly in there yeah exactly
there and it had really good bones but
the only thing is it was had like a
thousand more square feet than we needed
and it was like 75 thousand more than we
had already like like budgeted for yeah
max budget no 70 over our max what I
just thought it was like a little bit
beyond what we had I don't know it was
well that the scope had crept I think
those within our approved loan amount it
was it was within our approved loan
amount looking at the baby wasn't it
wasn't no what no cuz we we we offered
our the max the we got like our approved
loan amount we had decided okay our
personal max is significantly lower the
word before cuz we didn't want to use up
the whole thing but this house is even
beyond at the approved loan amount so
really cool just offer at the top of the
approve
because I had already looked at like 30
houses and not some houses so many
houses and we were getting desperate and
they didn't take our offer which was a
blessing in disguise yeah because it it
was so much more expensive than like
this house hmm
was our current house but it's
interesting like when we walked into our
current house we made an offer while we
were still in the house
yeah yeah we did read this this is it
let's put an offer
let's go we'd already looked at so many
this is the right price it was very near
be like area then um you know we had
found that the first house in like we
just knew immediately looking at the
bones of it that we don't do some really
cool stuff with it yeah and the price
was very reasonable the price was so
reasonable
we offered more because it's like it was
so low that there was like a little bit
of a bidding there's other offers but we
like we also wrote a letter to the
homeowner
and we're like hi We're first-time
homeowners we'll be getting married soon
we're so excited like we really want
this house to be our first house and we
really love it and please pick us that
was one of the tips from our realtor
that was like you know write a letter
yeah if you're in a bidding war write a
letter
yeah you know if someone hasn't cut
feels like they have more of a
connection with you they might pick you
so we bought the house and the house
that were in is a very first house
obviously in terms of home ownership
experience we didn't have much at all I
mean like I think I think it was
experience well I think the question so
the first one was why'd you decide to
buy your house that's what we just kind
of covered the next part of the question
was what level of experience did you
have when you started I think that's
experience with like renovation well we
started renovating right away like we
didn't have but we didn't have
experience but yeah so it's like you
know my parents had renovated a house in
the past when I was like 13 and you know
my parents owned lots of houses because
we moved a lot but personally I had zero
experience renovating houses doing
anything big yeah I had dear and you
know all of the knowledge that we had is
from research like looking at blogs like
Halen looked at blogs and I might have
looked at like a few YouTube videos but
I mean that's that's it we didn't have
any practical experience yeah and there
there were things that we hired out you
know some of it we did ourselves and
some of it we hired out and some we did
both some some we tried to do with
ourselves and then we had to hire it out
anyway so some examples are one thing we
hired out that I'm so glad we hired out
because it's it's something that if
you're gonna do it it's so much easier
if you do it before you move in and that
is change changing the floors yes so the
whole house was like like a beige carpet
and black like this white tile with
black grout that was really cracked
badly and a lot of places weren't there
like multiple tiles there's one in the
entrance one in the kitchen one in the
same
I forgot I've blocked it all out in our
guest room renovation video back to get
old photos of the guest room and I was
like oh my god our house and so we hired
out someone doing the floors and I'm so
glad we did because there was like when
they pulled up the carpet there was a
pitcher's mound of concrete under the
carpet so much foundation issues they
they said that they had not seen
something with this many well the the
foundation issues were past the
foundation was fixed but look the clean
up after the foundation swab repairs was
super sloppy and they're like we've
never had to grind down and build up and
grind down and build up with so much
foundation yeah we would have been so
much over our heads we wouldn't have
known at all what to do in that in that
case yeah and we didn't want to get a
storage unit or anything furniture so
hiring that out I think was a good idea
um Oh a flooring a flooring thing that
we did try to do a laundry room yeah we
tried to put down tile yeah well they
had they the floor guys had removed the
the old cracked tile but we didn't want
the wood floors in there cuz it's a
laundry room tile floors and what we
should have done is just hired them to
do the tile floors yeah in there but we
were like we can do that ourselves
yeah space but that area they because
they were already like machines in there
like laundry machines in a fridge when
they were leveling all the ground if
they didn't level that area like they
didn't move that and so that's what we
were trying to do we were trying to pour
like the quick-set
area and oh god we just made it worse so
we just had like mounds of lumpy
concrete in hard dining room and I think
my laundry room so I think we ended up
calling that same company and being like
do you guys do tile - yeah you know bike
you know we wouldn't have known what we
couldn't could didn't like you know we
just didn't know that like what our
limits were until we tested them I'm
glad we tested well and an interesting
thing is yes I almost forgot that this
happened because we had done all the
research to DIY it ourselves like we
didn't we didn't have the skills to do
it but like we knew the proper steps and
we had done so much research before I
called back the people that did our
floors yeah I called someone that was
like specifically tile yeah because you
know but with the flooring we didn't
know if they did tile as well so I just
found some tile installer that got good
reviews on Yelp or whatever and called
them to come do it and we had our tiles
I forget if our tiles now were supposed
to cut them with a wet saw yeah and I
knew that because I'd done the research
and I was like preparing for us to have
to cut them and this guy kept cutting
our tiles not with a wet saw and kept
shattering them and you you were at work
again I worked from home so I was at
home and I was kind of like monitoring
this guy he just kept breaking our tiles
and these were you know we didn't he'd
gone through almost a whole box of tiles
breaking them and I was like you need to
use a wet song he's like
it's just it's just your tile and I'm
like there's not tiles you're using the
wrong type of saw and he was kind of
arguing it asked him to leave I think we
like paid him partially for like the
beginning of the work ya know what's
what's right and what's wrong and stand
up for yourself yeah exactly and I I had
done the research and I knew and he was
breaking all of our tiles we would've
had to cope by more tiles like a
significant amount more and so yeah it's
interesting doing the research let us
feel more confident in knowing like what
the issue was
yeah so even if you are gonna hire it
out make sure you know what it looks
like like what it should look like at
the end when it's done properly even
like you know what the process the
process is yeah even like in the Attic
III even know what proper electrical
wiring should look like you know it
shouldn't be like dangled on the floor
and pulled tight and everything but like
sometimes this is it's tough to like
summon that extra energy to like make
sure it's done right and check it
afterwards and you know stand up for
yourself but if you don't sloppy works
gonna get done and even like though I
knew we needed to do that sometimes
would have worked on and I wouldn't
supervise it and check it enough and
like you know we have this cable running
across the entrance to the attic that's
a high voltage wire and it's like
running across the opening yeah of the
so wrong why did I
I don't like disparage this guy but at
the same time it's like do things right
I don't know you just gotta advocate for
you just gotta advocate yourself yeah
yeah so what was our level experience
when we started zero but the only way to
learn is to start doing it and I I think
that like yeah I don't know do you think
that more people are gonna keep on
buying houses or do you think a lot of
people ders can Arendt in the future
going forward like our generation and
these are different generations I mean I
think the trend is towards renting these
days but it's like everything is the
trend is everything is kind of pushed
later people are getting married later
people are buying houses later people
are having kids
later so I I think the house buying is
is kind of tied to that so I I see
people continuing to wait later yeah to
buy a house but I don't know if like
overall house buying will go down or not
I don't know I don't know enough about
like the real estate market and stuff
like that I don't know either for us
financially made a lot of sense even
though I you know we do have to take on
you know repairs every now and then but
you know I your luck varies depending on
your house and I guess your luck you
know if there are expensive things
needed every now and I like the air
conditioning and ducts and there's just
a lot that goes into it but at the same
time if you're living in a house and
you're renting it and you need to keep
on calling or someone to repair things
and they're not doing the best job I
think that'd be even more frustrating
usually if you're living in an apartment
you're renting it I feel like it's maybe
slightly faster because to get stuff
repaired it was it was pretty fast for
me to get stuff repaired whenever on it
like my old apartment and stuff yeah
because I feel like like the apartment
complex it has X amount of units meaning
they're able to keep their like team of
repair people busy like they they're on
site more yeah you know because there's
like more units take care where if
you're if you're renting a house and the
person renting it from it just this is
this might be their only rental yeah you
know it's not as easy for them to like
call up their person and have them there
immediately because they don't have a
power because like an apartment even if
they outsource it you know having an
apartment complex is a like huge client
you know so it's like oh we gotta we
gotta take care of the apartment complex
before we go and fixes one guys whatever
problem yeah what was that was that when
you started building your tool Arsenal
or did he have a lot of tools to begin
with when we when we moved in together
we had zero tools between us yeah at the
apartment yeah and then our first tools
we got we got for the wedding
to start DIY the letters we got a jigsaw
a hammer
alright to drill the holes yeah yeah
there's a drill with a hole saw bit
which is like a spade bit the cheapest
one like the one dollar a hole bit so
you know we started our first projects
with like less than a hundred dollars
were the tools and we just started there
yeah yeah that's all we had in the
apartment and then when we moved here we
just kind of started buying things I
think the next thing we bought were some
wrenches for plumbing yeah cuz we yeah
we didn't buy the circular saw for a
long time or miters or anything we
started buying a few things um because
we we had the blog where we were
documenting fixing up our house yeah and
that led to making a few small pieces of
like furniture and things so we got like
the miter saws we made that side table
we made that bench yeah we made the
scratching post that was oh the original
original scratching post yeah we made
the scratching post so we we were doing
a few small woodworking projects yeah
that we though we did on the blog so we
have like I love the miter saw I know we
do it's so easy but I think that the
approach of just buying the tools that
you need for the projects that you're
gonna be working on I think that's the
best approach I think we've said that
multiple times before but I don't think
like pre purchasing tools that you don't
have a use for that's not like don't buy
the tools and assume the projects are
gonna come to you yeah
find the projects and then get what you
need to make that project a success yeah
because we we've bought we've done it
the other way and we sold tools that we
haven't used liquid funds like
sledgehammer okay besides the
sledgehammer that was an impulse buy on
my I was like what if there's zombies
eventually no no
I know I know in my head I was thinking
I just want a sledgehammer also that and
there's a cool hammer it's a big hammer
anyways what else what else though okay
what are the tools have we gotten I mean
I ended up not using well it's not
really tools but we have bought stuff
for future projects like we were going
to replace every outlet every switch so
we bought all of them we've gradually
been doing it over six years they're
still we still with bag switches and
outlet covers we bought them we first
moved into the house yeah and we still
haven't done that yes well it's like you
know like oh we bought and this again
isn't tools but we bought a bunch of
like tile related stuff oh yeah because
we're gonna re-grout really without his
reseal stuff then really regrouting is a
lot of work all the stuff so okay just
buy things right before you're gonna do
the project next next question were
there any surprises or things you
weren't expecting to have to fix I think
you're expecting most things I didn't
think we were expecting a plumbing
issues so early on because we started
experiencing that like right away yeah
well no we were expecting them because
the inspector told us that there were
some minor leaks oh okay oh yeah he did
right yeah so like we knew we were gonna
have to do some plumbing stuff and that
I think we've told the story before but
so that was like one of our first
projects I was very stressful um one
thing that I wasn't expecting is there
was just all these like mystery cables
and wires yeah everywhere in the house
and we found out that they were tied to
like an old alarm system that was no
longer like president king yeah I am so
we had this whole ordeal of and I guess
I could have just left them but they
really bothered me they're just be like
a wire coming out of the wall that just
went nowhere and just ended and I'd be
like what the heck is that they're
probably like they're probably no no
when we bought the house everything had
been repainted in the cheapest and most
horrible of paints ever all like ceiling
it's more matte than matte it's like
it's like paper like it shows every
single mark shows every single marker
basically that is they took the home
security system and in the repaint of
our entire house
that's one like you just have all these
like leftover cables they just snipped
everything out and then repainted over
everything and including the cables yeah
so as all these cables like still on the
wall just with mysterious ends and then
nowhere and like that really bothered me
and so we spent a decent amount of time
up in the attic like tracing cables to
the wall and pulling them out and we got
we had like a whole huge nest of cables
remember that we got rid of so many
cables so many cables yeah it was it was
like literally a huge giant nest and
they're all like down in our like AC
intake
yeah and we got a seal around that and
everything yeah so that was one that I
didn't expect like you hear things like
plumbing things and oh you're gonna have
to repaint and this one one thing we
didn't understand how big of a deal it
was but our insulation and the Attic was
just like it looks like like a Tasmanian
Devil had just like twirled around up in
our attic like oh the bass we're just
like laying all over haphazardly torn
off the walls there's this like you know
electrical work and other work has been
done where they need to remove it but
just no one put it back up so it's just
like left in piles like spaghetti hair
wires all over the place in the attic
that whole project required so much more
work than I was expecting in the project
we're referring to was blowing our own
insulation just cuz of all the prep work
so much blowing it was like that was a
day's worth of stuff I'm glad they were
doing a really good job of convincing
people to buy homes
[Laughter]
I'm so glad pretty minimal issues and a
lot of the things that we did were
brought upon us by ourselves nothing
yeah nothing was really necessitated
that much except for like a few plumbing
issues that we could have and we could
have just hired it out right at the
beginning it would have been like
$10,000 that's that's a lot of money you
know five thousand two thousand oh no if
we had have had all of the plumbing and
our entire house all replaced with like
PEX piping and all of that
yeah that would have been several
thousands of dollars but we still don't
have that all we did was replace the
leaky parts like $100 worth of like we
learned things yeah but you know it's
like when you think about like the the
value of the house and everything and
like the the money we saved by buying
like an older house I think that like
buying an older house and fixing it up
even if you're like paying people for
like the major things like a/c plumbing
electrical electrical yeah that's my
Matt your money back out out of or
something wait what do you think that
that's what makes sense to spend money
oh well yeah I mean I think it makes
sense to spend money elsewhere but like
you I'm not sure how much like you know
if we if we paid someone to strip all of
the walls in the entire house and
repaint them with a nicer paint the
value of the house wouldn't have been
reflected oh you're saying in terms of
like value value I was thinking more in
terms of like like we didn't want
carpets so like the value does nothing
like the value of the house in a way
yeah I think the biggest thing is just
that yeah even though some of the money
you pay every month like interest you're
just losing it yeah some of it you're
putting towards an asset that you then
can sell or rent or whatever overall if
something makes sense monetarily and
fiscally they like get a house at least
maybe in a different situation in our
situation because Texas has very low
house prices oh yeah some people don't
live where we live fancy places where
it's very expensive yeah that's why we
don't want to move to like downtown LA
yeah the cost of living here is
appropriate yes so let's see what was
the hardest part of doing the
renovations for each of you I think that
for me it's just it's very tiring you
know like going to work and coming back
home and
like eating and then because like my
schedule was bad I'd like go to work I'd
come home at like 6:00 6:30 odd maybe
shower would eat together and then would
work until like 10:30 there's just like
going to work and then working more
later it was just you know it's like
similar hours to now except it was a
soul-crushing job soul-crushing job I
think I think the part of the main part
of it is just like the energy that it
took I don't think that really any
individual part of it was so I think for
me that bad I think for me there are two
hard things one hard thing is because we
are so new at it there is a fear from me
of like making something worse putting
lunch of time into something then making
it worse and having to hire it out
anyway like we did with the tile
bathroom the shower the master shower
situation fixing the grout in the shower
you spent so much time in there just
scraping yeah well we had so tell the
whole story but there's there's a master
bathroom story where Caitlin spent a lot
of time trying to fix something and then
we ended up just hiring it out yeah but
then like even they didn't do a great
job they didn't do a great job and then
now now we need to fix it again
yeah exactly so but but I think like
that is a frustrating thing that I feel
like it's kind of hard to know if you're
if you're gonna end up in that situation
until you're there yeah you're right of
like putting all this time like you put
your own time and money into it and then
you have to hire it anyway so like that
was kind of a struggle um I think
another part is that and maybe this is
part of the reason why we did like share
these things on the blog but a lot of
the stuff we were doing especially when
we first moved in there wasn't like a
visible pay out when you're done blowing
the insulation removing all those wires
it's like well things in the Attic are
more right now yeah but it's like the
house didn't look any different
yeah and so I think that can be kind of
frustrating cuz you know some home DIY
stuff is pretty you repaint a room and
you're like what
out this looks very different now you
change out a light fixture wow that's so
great you renovate your laundry room
boom yeah huge payout yeah it looks
awesome but there are also a lot of
problems where there's no visible
difference and even though in your head
you you know that it's it's right or
it's better or whatever now you don't
get to like see that or like man it
stink if like our our furnace blower and
our attic broke in a major way that we
had to replace it because that'd be like
a huge cost and all sorts of time and
trouble and all of that and then nothing
would be different yeah you know yeah
that's just a straight cost thing I
don't know I brought it up and within
the home renovation I mean it's not
something that we would do attempts to
DIY but I think when you are doing it
yourself it's it's easier to stay
motivated when you're like seeing
progress and you just enjoy the progress
speaking of which we had a question
related to that what was like your
favorite part of the whole process where
once you were done you're like yes this
was so worth the time okay so in terms
of things we did ourselves I think like
one of the the spaces that that has made
the biggest difference um it's actually
one of the ones we did reason somewhat
recently and that was a laundry room
mm-hmm
where like it was all cosmetic we didn't
change the footprint of the room you
know like where the machines are we we
didn't have to like everything was
cosmetic yeah and so but it but it made
such a big difference so it was like not
a crazy intimidating level of difficulty
even though it still took a lot of time
it just it wasn't anything too too
stressful what's interesting to me is I
thought I knew you're going to choose
that and that was my first thought too
then I started like thinking back like
because that was the most dramatic like
before and after it's like it was bad we
put a concentrated dose of time and do
it and it was better but you know my
favorite place in the room is whether we
put a ton of work into the living room
oh yeah you know it's like I love our
living room I love it I love spending
time in there it's
so cute and cozy harder to think about
gradually we did it gradually when we
first moved in we just threw some like
IKEA cabinets up against the wall and it
was ugly it didn't fit the space
everything about it was completely wrong
we had this huge long of amazing wall we
had this huge nice amazing wall and we
just had like a tiny console and two
tall things next to it which was like
spaced for like what we had in our
apartment and then we just put our like
ugly couches in front of that and are
like yeah that's the start you know but
over like the past five six years we've
slowly been improving I think the
biggest moment is when we replaced those
tall and minee like the tall and skinny
home entertainment setup with like a
really long low row of cabinets from
Ikea and we put the glass countertops
over all of it that was like a huge
moment for us and then when we got the
giant rug and the really nice couch yeah
but we did other things too like we
replaced a dated-looking fan with a new
fan we had kind of like a dirty brass
kind of dated looking fireplace that we
sprayed with our like high temp matte
dark like black we had a trouble tree
that was growing over on top of our
house we basically chopped it down with
chain saws hung above the fireplace yeah
there's a ton that we did that room it's
just like spread out over so many
individual projects and we never have
like a before and after and there's no
there's no videos done yeah well link to
a blog post photos of like when we how
it looked early but then we we we have
some photos of like at the mid point we
don't really have photos of how it is
now but also it's like we have like the
resin geo table over in the corner with
like a fake plant that we found on our
streets set out for trash that Kaelin
rescued and we have hung like a string
lights in it and we have all the
lighting just the perfect level of
coziness we have our love letters from
our wedding our love letters it's like
that room is just a happy place for us
my favorite room yeah we don't really
think of it as before-and-after because
it's been so many small things so true
yeah cuz it wasn't just like we tackled
it over a week but honestly that's what
the majority of people that's how most
people tackle a room you like say okay
we're gonna place this entertainment
unit okay we're gonna replace the lights
okay we're gonna get a new couch okay
we're gonna get a new chair okay we're
gonna get a side table and we're gonna
decorate like this and the tetris small
changes over time add up into something
that's really really great yeah that
kind of leads me to like another thing
that I was going to say is I think like
light fixtures or maybe very
intimidating because it's like oh
there's wires involved some of the
easiest replaced 90% of the lights in
our house and we did all of those
ourselves and I feel like that makes
such a make such a big difference
like those we replaced every fan in our
house except for one which we are about
to do well today or tomorrow or tomorrow
and I feel like that makes such a big
difference taking it from like a
dated-looking fan or light fixture to
something new it's very easy totally
doable by yourself and I think I just
think that that makes a huge difference
which is the way we've done it in
literally every room yeah yeah well
thank you again
black hearth creation the spores the
question that was really good if you
guys want to submit some questions go to
our community page on our YouTube
channel go to youtube.com slash evident
view and podcast go over to the
community tab and we'll have a topic
suggestion thread over there where you
can leave some questions for us to
tackle in the next podcast but now it's
time for a thing of the week
my thing of the week is one of William
Osmonds latest videos where he replies
to spam emails and like it's a I don't
want to spoil too much but like but the
premise is like okay so so if you are a
content creator or like an Instagram
influence are things like that you get a
bunch of spam emails asking you to
review products don't care who you are
they're such a dear sir on the damn yeah
and and you just your email gets clogged
up with him and so basically what he did
is to troll them he accepted one of them
made a fake review video and I'm not
gonna say what happens in the fake
review video and then like tried to get
a reaction out of them but you have to
watch it it's so good the setup is so
good it reminds me in some aspects of
like a Sofia video where she's she sets
it up really well he set it up really
well and like to follow through he
really did like he follows her commits
and he is like was trying to take it a
hundred percent you know what I mean
one of my favorite parts honestly is
like the reaction between him and the
person he was emailing at the end yeah
so good so yeah we'll have a link to
that it was a really good video yeah and
my thing of the week it was a present
that I received and it's an espresso
machine and I am someone who likes
coffee with like a lot of milk I mostly
milk just a little bit of coffee
and it's I had held off on buying an
espresso machine because they can be
super super expensive yeah like hundreds
or like over a thousand dollars and I
was like it just is hard to justify that
cost especially cuz like I also drink a
lot of tea so I kind of go through
phases but also it's like like let's
clarify here Kaelyn loves coffee in the
fact that she likes really strong coffee
with a lot of milk so I was like
preparing the next thing I was gonna say
then I thought other huh
okay great contribution I feel
embarrassed now okay go on and and so
because like I'm half the time or it's
someone two thirds of the time like a
tea drinker and you know the rest of the
time coffee it just seemed like not
justified buying a fancy espresso
machine but then I was like you know
what I'm just gonna see what else is out
there and I found this one on Amazon for
$59 that had super great reviews and I
know that there are things you can do to
make like a strong cup of coffee that's
like a stovetop thing but all the
reviews while the reviews were good it
was also like it takes 15 minutes to
make a cup of coffee
wrong coffee right now I don't know
sometimes it just feels like you don't
have and so I was like ah man I guess I
could get one of those but I would like
something that does it faster but I
found this little espresso machine I put
it on my wish list and I got it for a
present yeah and it's really really good
yeah it only does one thing but it does
it well whistles it has a milk frother I
have the milk frother yet but like you
can make a two cup or a four cup yeah
you know it's great for you know it
wouldn't be good for like an office
where you have a ton of people sharing
and like drinking from the same thing
yeah um but it was it's super easy to
use it's very simple it's very small
this is it's not too much to maintain
and clean and stuff
no no I haven't the use of rent stuff
yeah you know but I like that it's
really small it's like the size of my
electric tea kettle I use for tea it's
not a big smaller than like a Keurig
yeah so we've really been liking it yeah
and I know that she doesn't listen to
the podcast but thank you to my little
sister for yes he doesn't
well thank you guys so much for
listening and thank you guys for
spending some time with us we really
appreciate you guys and we look forward
to talking at you the next time
[Music]